Coenen in israel is going to air next
Tuesday September 19th at 10 o'clock
p.m. right here on TBS that's gonna be a
pretty fascinating travel show at the
Lord or it's a complicated country we
explore you know a lot of different
parts of Israel and obviously there's a
lot of issues we try and take a fair
look at everything just to give you an
idea of how sophisticated this special
will be here's a clip of me on the beach
in Tel Aviv
atencion atencion
this is Conan O'Brien shabbat shalom
this is an important announcement we'll
all Israeli men wearing Speedos
please leave the area again all Israeli
men wearing Speedos
leave immediately no one wants to see
your junk
[Applause]
yeah that's right
I tried to address the really sensitive
cultural issues on my visit as you saw
so be sure later but I do think it's
gonna be a great program to watch our
primetime special Conan in Israel airing
next Tuesday September 19th at 10
o'clock p.m. and check out all the great
Conan in Israel extras there's gonna be
a lot of them because we shot a lot of
stuff at team koco.com slash Israel
you